hey youtubers is Charlie and we found
out this week on arrow when you tell
people the truth they totally get struck
by lightning especially if you are
Felicity seriously there were so many
big moments I actually had to expand my
top 5 to top 10 so this is actually
gonna be a little bit longer than normal
just because there is so much awesome to
talk about if anyone was watching
Twitter Stephen Amell totally tweeted
that Miley Cyrus line I came in like a
wrecking ball the way he wrote it though
you have to imagine that he was singing
it it was really funny if you're finding
me for the first time I typically do
arrow videos every Wednesday and then
Q&A is on Thursday be sure to subscribe
to get everything
it's kind of like my DC time during the
week so since there is so much awesome
I'm gonna do top 10 moments then I'll
list as many comic book references as
possible and do my review so careful for
potential spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet but here we go
number 10 Slade recruits an army he's
going to turn all those prisoners into
super soldiers and just let brother
blood use them to take over the city
this also tied back into what Diggle was
saying at the beginning there's too many
prisoners since Oliver stopped killing
him thus Slade's army is born they were
all headed to Starling city's version of
Arkham so they're basically grade 8
psychos also here's an image of all
those people with full-on Deathstroke
gear on someone captured it from the
city of blood episode they're all
dressed up like Slade pretty freaking
sweet huh number 9 Sara tries to suicide
bomb Slade WTF this was really important
for shadowing for a future WTF moment I
think first off Sara is super dark there
was even that line when did you get so
bad David nickel from Stargate goes all
WTF on her it failed but I think she's
gonna try and use that idea again during
present day only what if she turns
herself into a bomb let me know if you
agree please don't die caity lotz
suicide bombing Deathstroke wouldn't
work anyway mirakuru can heal anything
except for this number 8 Oliver's fight
montage on route 2 Slade Stephen Amell
actually posted a behind-the-scenes
video of this whenever they were
practicing it like the day-in-the-life
videos he does on Facebook it was months
ago and at the time he couldn't say
anything about it first off though
arrows stunts are just awesome and this
in his own words was one of the biggest
and most well choreographed montages all
season long I definitely agree one of
the best fight sequences overall
it's also interesting because you have
to think about the time jump between the
production and the episodes actually
airing just this week he did another
post saying they only had about 12
episodes left or so shooting this season
and it takes over a little week to shoot
an episode so that means that they're
basically filming the finale like right
now as we speak so I'll talk more about
that later
number 7 Oliver and Slade totally catch
up at the police station this was their
first real moment together since the
island I don't consider that scene
outside the car during the promise to be
a full moment just because he was
basically bitch-slapping Oliver at the
time this time in the police station was
their first you know real sit-down in
chat moment they're not just spitting
threats and flexing muscles at each
other let me know if you thought this
too but whenever Slade was chained up it
reminded me of Leoben on Battlestar
Galactica
when Starbuck was interrogating him and
called him out for being a Cylon she
didn't believe him and to prove it he
snapped the metal cuffs like tissue
paper and just flipped the table over I
was kind of disappointed that Slade
didn't do that Slade was basically just
doing all these things though to create
distractions for Oliver while he creates
this super soldier army you know telling
Thea about Merlyn telling Laurel about
Oliver and going his company out from
underneath him number 6 Slade totally
hallucinate shado whenever they
announced the episode Marc Guggenheim
said we've learned what the mirakuru had
done to his brain and what's been going
on in his head for the last five years
and we literally got a picture of that
the shadow that we saw in the episode
isn't someone with superpowers
I mean she's not still alive she's not
secretly a metahuman it's just him
talking to himself like his mind created
an evil imaginary friend that's just
telling what to do and say remember how
he was speaking the words that shadow
was speaking let's call that shadow
hallucination Slade too and the you know
real Slade Slade prime after we saw her
don't you feel like Slade prime is still
in there somewhere and before the end of
the season we'll see him again in the
police station he said he hasn't been
able to get the quote-unquote island out
of his head for the last five years so
in all those current day scenes you have
to picture shado telling him what to do
and say to Thea Laurel everyone else
she's like an evil Tinkerbell just
pulling the strings after the reveal of
shado
I feel like you know this whole revenge
plot against Oliver
is something a third by her by this evil
imaginary Tinkerbell in sleights head
and Slade is just a puppet being used
number five
Slade tells Thea about Merlin he did it
just to drive a wedge between Oliver and
his family you know he's trying to
isolate him I actually expected to see
Merlin appear out of the shadows
whenever she left the police station I
think that were meant to take away that
she and Roy just split town temporarily
that doesn't mean that Merlin won't come
back soon in the qat that Stephen Amell
posted before the episode he said the
person that he liked to fight again
would be the dark Archer because they
have unfinished business and he also
talked in a different post about seeing
lots of old faces while they were
filming the finale obviously after this
episode I think we have to assume that
he was talking about one you know shadow
being back for more slate hallucination
scenes but I also think he was talking
about John Barrowman
being back on set - but that's
unconfirmed number for Slade reveals
Oliver's identity - Laurel just another
distraction as he put it but I love
laurels reaction you saw her eyes
darting around as if she was suddenly
putting all these pieces together
I think she'll actually end up being an
asset to team arrow you know in the
twist of what Thea's reaction was laura
has already spent most of the season
self-destructing so I think she's going
to become the next honorary member of
team arrow before the end of the season
there was this really ominous thing the
producer said at Comic Con during 2012
that I just have to mention they said
Laurel will become the Black Canary
later than you hope but sooner than you
expect
which is not good news for Sarah for
more on that please refer back to my
number nine top moment about Sara's
suicide bombing Slade number three
losing more friends
Roy quits team arrow I flipped just a
little whenever I saw Roy lose his
all over Diggle and Sarah pull the arrow
on him I felt like he would explode at
some point this season and I think this
was it he didn't join Team Deathstroke
but he did skip town with the up of
course we all fully expect him to be
back in time to help Oliver defeats
Slade but he wasn't in the trailer for
the next episode so it's probably gonna
be a little while Oliver's friends and
family have just been deserting of one
by one which is Slade's plan but it's
only going to get worse
episode 19 will feature killer frost one
of the villains from the new flash TV
show and vibe 5 was a good care
in the comic book so hopefully he'll
help out team arrow at some point and on
to number two Oliver versus Isabel
rochev or Rose Wilson or ravager or
whatever you want to call her let's just
be honest and say what we're thinking
here Ravager even if they're still
sticking with the Isabel rochev name she
has the fighting skills of ravager and
dropped all these references about sins
of the father she was mostly referring
to Oliver's father because you know her
name Isabel was on his list the list
from season 1 but I also think that
could have been a subtle reference to
Slade being Ravagers real father if she
puts on battle gear at some point this
season it looks remotely like Slade I'm
just gonna lose my
she has history with Slade that predates
Starling city and she knows all about
the island
I don't remember from season 1 but did
Slade know all about that list Oliver's
father gave to him but if Isabel is not
his daughter
then he'd only have known her connection
to the Queens if he'd seen her name on
the list which is just more evidence
that she really is Rose Wilson back in
that Russia episode she did talk about
growing up without her real father so
it's possible that Isabel rochev is just
her adopted name but let me know if you
agree and my number 1 moment so much
awesome here the evil Trinity becomes
team Deathstroke it's like Slade is evil
Superman Isabel is evil Wonder Woman and
brother blood is evil Batman evil
Trinity for the win I'm just gonna refer
to them as team Deathstroke from here on
out
I love how brother blood is basically on
a need-to-know basis with Slade in
Isabel seems to just know everything
this makes me wonder if Slade will
double-cross him at some point or use
him as a metaphorical human shield
against team arrow after all this there
are still a few huge questions that I
have you know namely when did Slade
start working with Isabel and after
Slade uses his super soldier army to
take Starling city 1 what's he gonna do
with the city and - what's he gonna do
with all those soldiers the army just
seems like a means to an end you know as
does picking the city I don't think he
cares about ruling a city so does that
mean he's planning on just destroying
everything ecker he's done it kind of
makes me think of in the comics whenever
Hal Jordan as parallax destroyed coastal
city like literally wiped it from the
face of the map but now it's your turn
let me know what was your favorite
moment and what do
think that Slade is intending to do with
the city once he's done with it and with
all those super soldiers overall the
episode was a solid a plus you know one
of the first a pluses that I've given to
any episode this season there were so
many big moments I actually had to
change my video from top 5 to top 10
just to make room the rest of the season
is just gonna be them jamming on the
accelerator towards this final
confrontation and hopefully an
appearance from Raja Ghul I just love
what Manu Bennett and the writers have
done for Slade's character this season
he definitely deserves his own spin-off
show I think I say that in every video
it would be just like Dexter you know
with more action told from the
perspective of Slade is the protagonist
to add to all that's happened this year
you know now we learned there's this new
added dimension of his crazy mind you
know shado telling him what to do like
evil Tinkerbell I just I can't wait to
see it all play out then there was that
last n teaser Oliver's comment you know
we go to war it's all about them going
on the offensive I had no idea how those
flash characters are gonna figure into
that but we will find out next week so
here's a couple of really awesome comic
book references that I mentioned but
didn't necessarily fit in my top 10
moments first off was Felicity's line
about telling someone the truth and them
getting struck by lightning just a nice
joke about Barry Allen Felicity for the
win
she always has the best jokes then there
was another giant Thea speedy name-drop
number three there was a reference to
brother I whenever Oliver mentioned
people in their orbit getting hurt
brother I was Batman's crazy satellite
that stored all the weaknesses of all
super humans on the planet and kind of
monitored them but it also could have
been a reference to the watchtower so
many WTF moments this is one of the best
episodes yet but because arrows on break
next week I'll be doing a bonus video
but I'll also be posting a Q&A video
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get
everything and leave all your questions
about this episode the rest of the
season in the comments below
you can actually click here to get that
video I'll add the annotation as soon as
I post that video tomorrow and you can
click here to get last week's
birds-of-prey episode thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives